alec mills will take the ball tonight
and with the reds hitting the ball out
of the ballpark a lot this is the night
to pitch yeah absolutely wind blowing
straight in cold conditions always
favorable for the pitcher the 0-1
bottle with a fly to left here comes
schwarber and he's got it the x-cub
castellanos
two bounces nice play by brian he'll
spin throw and get him jesse winker the
d-8 and the pitch
fly ball left field schwarber in
and that's a one two three for alec
mills when you're facing a ball club for
the third time in six starts that's
where mali is right now with the cubs so
they know him he knows them the more you
have confidence in your stuff the less
you worry about the other team and you
worry about the guy leading off because
ian happ has been setting the world on
fire 2-2 pitch
swing and a miss good start for mali and
now he'll go to work on chris bryant
how about mally strikes out the first
two batters he faces count as one and
one on rizzo
jam job
and a clean first inning for tyler
malley it's the start of 2018.
suarez has 95 home runs second most
behind just mike trout
hey he got him well located
his first strikeout this is jose garcia
22 year old rookie
yeah he got him good call
schwarber walked with one away contreras
and with an infield hit here's david
playing second base and the pitch from
mali bodhi hits a drive toward right
field castiano's going back hits over
his head it goes all the way to the wall
two runs will score
boate on his way to third the relay not
in time
cubs lead two to nothing
david bodie a two-run triple to the
opposite field and right you were just
saying pat how the outfield was playing
somewhat shallow and you could
understand because of the wind blowing
in you know javi mentioned he's not the
only star that's struggling at the plate
right now when he's going right center
he's got so much ability to hit the ball
hard that way that the hits will just
start coming
well struck to right and that's going to
get in there castillanos will chase this
one down
bryant waved in hobby to third he's got
a triple
little deja vu
three nothing sparrows has really been
struggling so if they're gonna have any
chance to get into the playoffs and make
a push they're gonna have to have this
offense start to fire on all cylinders
swinging a miss strike three second time
suarez has struck out brings up aquino
aquino strikes out swinging on a
curveball
that's number four for mills we get into
the sixth inning alec mills has been
terrific
called strike three
he's gotta go out here and attack and
get this next guy aquino
ground ball to third gobbled up by
bryant
mills gets through six without allowing
a run tonight all cubs so far
in the series opener and bae has a high
drive to left aquino on the warning
track makes the grab
on any other night
see the hanging little spinner cutter
there and baez gets the barrel on it he
thinks oh i got one
but like you said len not tonight any
other night that might have been out of
here but with the wind blowing in the
way it is you see how far that ball blew
too aquino running all the way from the
advocare
sign all the way to the toyota sign and
bias like what are you doing to me tyler
mally's still on the hill for the reds
given up four hits three runs they were
earned and eight strikeouts
breaking ball swinging a miss nine of
them and he'll face the nine batter
cameron maven
tyler o'malley ties a career high seven
innings pitched ten punch-outs ryan
tapera is on this will be his 16th
appearance he's got the top of the order
here
he got him looking underwood a scoreless
seventh and now to pera you're in the
eighth
and it'll be caught by bias
jeremy jeffress was looking for save
number
six swing and a miss got him on the
splitter one out one on cubs lead by
three in the ninth or akiyama
fly ball to left
half drifting
and he makes a grab two down
freddie galvez off the bench
ground ball bryant's got it cubs win
cubs win they take the opener
three-nothing they've got a three-game
lead in the division and david bode with
the big hit the two run triple in the
second